my hair looks great today I'm Greg no
there's nothing wrong with us here right
he wore an amazing win an amazing wear
Syd Wilder is here Syd wild her piled
her she's Jewish I am 100% she did a DNA
test choosy youtuber one of them
anything she is is a youtuber as well as
an awesome awesome channel seriously
some hilarious sketches on there I'm not
lying about that I'm not just trying to
promote it I'm telling you go to her
Channel and watch some of her sketches
she owes also on Instagram where it's
all very fully covered body photos not
revealing at all I don't like stare at
them constantly no no not at all oh
speaking of porn stars which she is not
by the way we're gonna watch a video
today called porn stars read their DMS
afterwards we can talk about our DMS yes
yes but let's see what some porn stars
have to say perfect as long as it's not
my sister as long as it's not I found
this out yeah there we go
alright for some nasty stuff we need to
hang out sometime please do it for me
your grace and
[Music]
Wow
keep up the great work whoa hey there
serve up that mic I would still like to
marry you okay pornhub there you go
pornhub yeah
pornhub really has become like
the hub dominant porn site huh I'm just
glad it's not you porn if it's pornhub I
mean maybe pornhub owns you porn but
whatever cuz YouTube and you porn get
confused all the time I'm like no no I'm
the tube she's the porn
so you said you get sent a lot of dick
pics Oh a lot of dick pics I'm talking
through this experience I think and I'm
gonna do a video on this tube I'll give
you so as you know I like to do yoga I'm
not a centered as Jessi or as calm as
Jessi him a little bit more manic and
like you know out there Josie Josie
golden is an amazing celebrity yoga
instructor and not that I'm a celebrity
but she teaches actual slow you're
pretty famous I mean but I can still be
centered but I'm just not that's not
like how I carry myself 24/7 I'm a
little over the place everyone thinks
that I do like yoga and I meditate and
it practices it up this guy sends Jesse
and I a group message of him doing yoga
and this is after you know obviously it
was Jesse inspires me a lot I obviously
did on my Instagram some naked employee
nudity is taste bold artistic it wasn't
like you know ah here's my labia
um because you can't see it anyway
different story different story I can
really go off on tangents so he sent us
a naked video of him doing yoga and uh
pictures of him doing yoga and at first
it was all innocent
and like you couldn't see it he was kind
of doing an implied pose so jesse was
like you know really sweet oh great job
and she responded and then it just got
nudity and then it was the nude video
and then it was like crickets like we
were like oh my gosh weird
he's still comments my photos I'm
appreciative of that but cool don't send
me naked yoga pictures ever been turned
off like cuz I just never from a woman's
perspective I'm just like why would you
seen a dick turn a girl I just don't see
how it would be like I want that I think
it's aggressive I think it's disgusting
I think it's offensive
like I just and I I mean as a woman but
like you know of course I'm gonna laugh
at it and send it to my friends and I'm
definitely considering like putting it
on my Instagram story giving that person
a shout-out and drawing on it like why
do you do this
cuz I'm just gonna cut it out for it but
then like I don't know if I'm giving
them publicity in a way and then people
are gonna follow I don't really know how
to handle it but I'm trying to figure it
out do girls ever try to like sing oh
that's an interesting questions it's
confusing because I have like people are
like oh like we really think you're hot
like couples will reach out to mean I'm
like no I'm not interested I don't want
to have a threesome I'm like that's
disgusting I don't share that's not my
thing like no and I'm not into girls I
don't care if you are I support
everything and I'm not nervous at all no
I'm very straight I'm very very I tried
it not for me but I'm very straight
that's why I'm like I can tell you right
now love you totally support you but
don't try to [__] me not interested okay
it was a fair point that's where I
stands on that but no I've never had a
girl try to hit me up but it makes me a
little uncomfortable
when really yeah I have like in person
but I've never had it like online maybe
it was my sister maybe she drives all
the traffic to that my sister actually
hits on a lot of my friends and who's
really uncomfortable is sometimes not
all the time have you ever responded to
any of these guys who have sent you
photos
is there anybody ever been a guy we were
like he's actually pretty hot uh no no
it's been like a lot of those stupid
like no offense sorry they're not stupid
that was me Oh stupid douche bag
that's a better thing to say
no they see hi or like hey like that's
it and like there's I delete every
message that starts with higher hey and
then that's it because it's like is that
all you have to say like you think
you're so hot that all you have to say
it's high no like I don't care about
like guys hitting me up on GM's any of
that so I know I should be like cool but
I just don't care I've got an addicting
sent to me yeah how many several either
usually what do you do there then
usually no lie big black dicks what yeah
they're usually like a guy with some man
love your channel and then a photo of
their day no they're serious like they
have like their face in it and
everything and I love my cuz it's a real
guy yeah some people some guys put their
face in it you ever like do you ever
know love to respond actually I used to
lean it usually cuz I'm like it just
intimidates me if I see a dick that huge
is it really that big cuz I'm like hey
ya know they're huge
I don't know they're bloody did I meet
anything well I don't know I've never
been with a black man well or the
stereotype is that black guys tend to
have big dicks yeah I can't say yeah
sure you can I can't you just won't say
that like you can't ever tell I feel
like men are like surprise packages you
don't really know doesn't matter how big
your hands or your feet are you doesn't
matter how short or tall you are it's
like you just don't know you're gonna
get I've heard women don't like dicks to
be so most women actually don't like
dicks to be so big what if they just
don't like dick what if they just don't
like oh okay we won't talk about this
anymore no you can come in you're going
we're totally tanked should I open the
door
[Music]
she's still Georgia my mom we're still
family we're just wrapping up an episode
which I'm so glad we got this one out of
the way thank you
so I love God yeah I mean to wrap on my
end of it I've had girls like hit me up
before like honestly I thought it was
cool with it it's flattering it was
flattering and at the time I thought it
was hot because I'm like this girl looks
hot but then after a while it wasn't it
wasn't that long after where I was like
this is just feels kind of empty and
meaningless and at the same time it's
like if you live like in another state
and we have no potential Aviva meeting
up at all I've always wondered what it
would be like to be that guy who can
just like sleep with women you know
oh I mean there's many of the mountains
many of them and I know so many
everybody mean that's basically every
guy I know in LA every guy I know has
slept with way more women to me I've
been in like two relationships that
lasted long-term so I've only been with
like three women in my life first time
I'm sure there was this all the time
where that would make me pretty insecure
honestly the thought of like every guy
know has been in every girl I've heard
I've read articles on google.com that a
guys who are in long-term relationships
tend to be better in bed cuz they you
know they have to keep it exciting there
I need to communicate like you like what
you don't like a girl you have to learn
a field I'm like because you know the
first time you have sex you're not just
gonna know everything and you talk about
it exactly so you just get better so
maybe I maybe I maybe it's I'm lucky
that way you are
less chance of catching anything oh yeah
no it's a dangerous world out there
every so many people have someone it's
scary
it's very scary you guys be safe be safe
all right guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects I would really appreciate it I
would especially appreciate it if you
would subscribe to the Syd Wilder
channel I'm telling you I mean she's
really funny obviously she's beautiful
but beyond that she's very talented she
writes on her own sketches do you direct
them too or do you sometimes yeah but
still like they're very well done
sketches and they're really funny
hysterical she's got a wonderful
Instagram age-appropriate yeah she does
exclusive content I try to like uplift
people yes and you know make people want
to work out yeah I primarily go just to
read them go for the articles yeah